so the integral part of the collection
was finding the right Elena yeah yes and
you guys have shown great enthusiasm in
casting and the Fitzpatrick capable so
tell us what the casting process was
like how did you know that she was the
right one
well it mean it started we Marcus was
casting and could really couldn't find
anyone that just really worked and then
coincidentally it was like us and
separately went to and the casting
director all separately and one of the
producers pinochle II he went to Mickey
in making money I saw a social network
that weekend and like on Monday
if one started talking and we're like it
was his social networking like who was
that girl who was like you know got the
beer thrown at her and did what we
wanted so much short hair and a certain
look and it was her talking about it was
like I have no clue who that is and then
then five but I like an hour later the
captain found out who she was contacted
her people and brought her in to read
and that was it and you know that that's
another character that I think for we
want guys to have a crush on her we want
everybody to feel like this could be my
sister my girlfriend this is a protector
this is someone who's gonna save herself
and far too often the horror movie gets
that wrong and thinks well she should be
in a white tank top and run and then in
the last act instantly know karate and
how to use a gun no there's no reality
to that we wanted to keep everything
real for our characters right down to
their blood
so our villain would have more to play
with and be more scary in a real way you
know those are all spinning plates as
the Ed Sullivan Show with a hundred
spinning plates on pool cue tips and we
have to keep them all running so
everybody feels vulnerable and Emma felt
real well and another one too like
usually you've seen horror movie is like
how do we know that she's gonna be
awesome later in the opening shot we're
in a room we pass over the karate trophy
oh he's a gravid yeah so when it gets to
yeah so we tried to make it more like
emotionally based where that she had you
know she has an impairment and so she's
grown up always having to try harder
than everyone else
and so in playing with her just her sort
of like temperament like she's can stay
calm and
cool and you know in most situations if
you stay calm and cool you can deal with
it as without having superpowers and so
we try to establish that early on with
her so when she's in that situation she
is scared and frightened all that which
is able to take a breath assess the
situation and then try to overcome it
you know when she she can she certainly
cannot fight hand in hand at hand with
the collector she could see she does for
like a minute and she gets thrown across
the room and practically killed and
that's just reality you know she's so so
you know and that all just comes from
our knowledge of horror movies having
been there before having seen them and
reacted like a normal fan you know like
we've been in that movie you're like oh
man you know she's gonna have to not
that it's banished that someone has to
like get down to the tank top and all
that but we just didn't want to do that
it's just
instead we put rope it's on every poster
and I wonder if she's gonna be sweaty
with perfect makeup yeah yeah in a
moment with anybody yeah she finally has
turned the tables on the collector she's
like oh like this say that if you've got
a stalker slash in your run you scream
you terrify and you hope and pray you
don't know if that feels real that lets
the villain be scared you don't want to
take the way the villains resources to
be scared
you